what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sockin super pumped to
be talking about ascension and quantum
leaps
we have Sydney campus joining us on the
show I said hi it's so good to be here
with you thank you for coming on the
program and the quantum leap yes and for
those who don't know the city's
background she is a visionary advisor
intuitive healer author of the empath
experience and host of the visionary
Souls podcast you can find her link in
the bio below Sydney campus comm also
her YouTube page has incredible videos
and all the interviews check those out
in her Instagram profile ok so Sydney we
love starting things off by asking our
guests are we really all one yes yes
right I don't know what does that mean
we talk about that all the time like
we're all one and we just get to be one
and that's it and what does it mean what
does that actually mean so I'm very
sensitive right now to when I notice
myself speaking like someone else's
language or regurgitating something else
that I've believed or heard or thought
for a long time but isn't necessarily
what is most true to me in this present
moment so I'm just gonna like take a
really deep breath and see what wants to
be shared right now we're all one what
does that mean each and every living
being is a reflection of the same source
consciousness literally reflecting
itself in the energy of every other
living being really with an underlying
desire to better understand simply that
to better understand
not even to just understand oneself or
understand another without any objective
other than to come into deeper
understanding is that then the purpose
is to come into that deeper
understanding I think so one way I like
to conceptualize reality this experience
of life it's to look at it like a game
and it really does feel that way you
know one of my favorite ways to share my
gifts and support others is through
working in the Akashic records and
channeling really just channeling
unconditional love acceptance and you
know the sense of understanding that
allows someone to arrive more clearly
into their own answers or sometimes just
better questions so they receive
guidance on their path to get more clear
on their purpose and something I
frequently see in that space is you know
this image of our lives on earth being
kind of dealt out in a series of
different games and I've literally seen
the image of like a lightening of the
library of the Akashic records the
library of all of the the experiences of
all the souls of all of the universes
and all of the timelines that have ever
been past present and future is there's
no time actually right so it's like
consider this library of all that has
ever happened and all that will ever
happen and in this library there's you
know a collection of all kinds of
different games different board games
that's how it appeared to me once
actually when I was in a past life
regression I saw this you know it was
like all these different board games
like there's candy and there's monopoly
there's the game of life there's chess
there's like every kind of game you
could imagine all of which have
different objectives all of which have
different kinds of players different
kinds of themes different ways to win
points different ways to win you know
different strategies all the different
varieties
like countless infinite and I think
that's a fun way to look at our lives
and the way that we come into earth
especially to try out different games
and different ways to play different
rules you know and then maybe part of
the the game is to self realize that
you're making the whole thing up and so
you can change the game anytime okay
whoo all right so this process of diving
into the reality the reason why it's
here seeing it and the layer that
pierces the veil there's some sort of uh
feels like different types of board
games systems of maybe board games the
word that used is play write play and
you also used earlier this understanding
this process of understanding this
oneness understanding itself this
oneness playing itself and there's so
many of these board game archetypes that
can be drawn from two on the play
unfolding mm-hmm
we've talked about this quite a bit on
the program that at times it feels like
the game of Risk has been played over
the period of time of these borders
shaping armies for meeting pushing yeah
that one was really deeply resonant and
even probably probably even more ancient
than that archetype is probably sims in
the first place
that pross the sims process and then you
get like risk and what now also feels
like monopoly in
waise is being played out like you
listed one of as one of the games
rent-seeking
in these metropolis feels like monopoly
in a sense get out of jail free get out
of jail free it's true it's so funny
it's a hologram we can literally see all
the games you know we can see that's
playing out all of the different and
simultaneously multiple different ones
right but when I find to be really
exciting as this opportunity right in
our attention and our awakening and our
self
you know realization that we are
creating the game is to you know Wow
like choose what game are you here to
play like and how do you want to play it
how do you want to show up you know and
what are all the different rules of
engagement that serve you that feel best
for you to learn and to understand what
it is that you're most called to explore
yeah I love that tie in that that you've
made now twice so the the board game
archetype stack of with within this one
we draw from in understanding what we
want to do what how we want to behave in
this big play that's unfolding and we
have this free will of deciding what we
want to do with these actions and
behaviors and what board games we want
to pull
mm-hmm from and does it feel then that
this these do you feel as though these
are also individual essences within the
one what do you mean I'm trying to
understand initial feeling is like yes
because it's all the one and we're all
different essences of the same you know
source consciousness and that makes
sense you know and
I don't think I understand though what
you mean maybe we don't understand what
either of us mean because we're hacking
reality so deeply these levels of
abstraction are intense
well because it's funny right in the net
points to the original like the original
you know pony I think of our disturbing
up is like the desire to simply
understand like maybe we're on earth I
have been really feeling this a lot
lately I don't know about you it's like
deconditioning from and I know we were
just talking about Charles Eisenstein
and something he wrote the other day
that really resonated with me that he's
a big proponent of is like just being
like deep commodifying
are you know just being this you know
like we're so hyper conditioned to be in
production and like creating and overly
identify with you know what we do and
like we sourced so much about your
condition to source our value based on
what we produce and what we do instead
of who we are and how we're being you
know and and there's this that's a huge
part of Ascension in this moment and our
collective awakening is this wow it's
such a deconditioning and to just pure
being and being okay with being being
being in love with being you know being
in joy with that like simplicity and I
was just speaking with someone earlier
today about this like there's just such
a massive deep programming of like the
way our brains are wired to be in
heightened survival mode and
fight-or-flight and you know like some
things out to get us and we were talking
about the default mode network mode
Network exactly right which is just
wired to go into worry to past worry
into future you know analysis and
judgment and just survival mode you know
because we actually get into a rest day
it's like that part of us is actually
you know needs to keep doing stuff and
needs work to do still you know it needs
homework so we're in this massive
invitation right now to do deep like
neurological nervous system brain weary
wiring that allows us to I believe being
more of our natural stay which is being
which is peacefulness which is like
probably pretty ecstatic maybe
you know and and then we we get to say
hey now that I'm being here now and I'm
fully present what naturally wants to
arise like through me what's my natural
creative impulse you know what is it
that I'm here to share what is it that
I'm here to really understand what am I
most excited about exploring you know
and then then we can talk about purpose
and your sole purpose your gifts your
genius all that kind of naturally can
just emerge yeah I'm happy that you're
bringing up the economic machinery sort
of choking out the process of just being
and that it's in a sense it serves its
purpose with our awakening by doing that
by doing this it's creating the pressure
cooker for the evolution that that we're
going through okay so we are now let's
say D commodifying so many of our ways
of behaving and focusing less on
necessarily this word productivity
always so this word balance comes up a
lot of balance of wanting to make art
and be and express yourself through the
means of producing but also of just
being is that is that word is that of
resonant word or feeling for for you I
think balance has been taken out of
context so much it's like this objective
like even balance becomes this thing
that you have to achieve and it's like a
race to be the most balanced two-person
you know what I mean like it's like what
does it even mean anymore it kind of
because for me it feels like it became
this thing that now suddenly I have to
do a lot of stuff to try to do it right
and be there and am i there yet
and it's like you know what program do I
have to do to be balanced and you know
and I don't know are we ever really what
does that mean and so let me try to
define that like what is balance when I
think about that word for me it means
like homeostasis which I very rarely
ever used that word but that's what just
came up and that to me means like
harmony like harmonious like integrated
homeostasis like rest like when some
things in homeostasis it's just like
stillness it's it's stable stability I
resonate a lot more with stability like
that's what I'm about cultivating less
than I feel like balance is something
that is like a moving target it was like
yo dough but stability wow that's
something I can feel its ability for me
is like my energy body my nervous system
my mental emotional state that's like
I'm stable and present I can be fully
present can be fully here so stability
then is being fully present being fully
here cultivating that is a main focus
would you say that that's the most
upstream issue that we face is
cultivating a sense of stability when
you put it like that yeah it feels
really clear I think that's it I mean
and then look at our whole economic
political media I mean all of the
structures all the infrastructure and
all the ideology they're in doesn't it
all kind of become dismantled if you
know fundamentally more individuals are
operating from a deep space of stability
calm you know like less of a react or no
reactivity know like impulsivity no like
meeting anything
I know you said that this word balance
seems like something that's a little bit
used in ways that are not necessarily
oriented towards the Ascension process
that we're actually aiming for it can be
sometimes detach why do I have to strive
towards this balance it feels like this
all is a balance all the time it's all
perfect all the time do you feel like
this is perfect the way it is and the
way it's evolving yeah sometimes it
sucks and sometimes it's awkward and
sometimes it's really confusing and and
all of that can happen in one minute or
one second like all of those experiences
are happening simultaneously there's
right now yes and even as you just said
what you just shared about balance like
my thought around balance just changed
you know and agree we're just speaking
about this earlier it's so funny how
fast were evolving faster shifting you
know sometimes I just wonder like should
I even talk because like I'll say
something and then five seconds later I
already disagree with what I just said
because something has already shifted in
my consciousness too you know where oh
wait what I just said no longer feels
authentic you know and I'm just
constantly kind of addressing and
correcting and and so what you said
actually about balance what I just
pictured was the scales being balanced
right and I pictured this like essence
of okay wait a minute there's something
powerful about that
mmm-hmm like equality equilibrium also
connected to homeostasis again yep why
did I have a resistance just going with
that though and but there's something
powerful about I think about energy
exchange to like balance like Bala it's
important to balance exchanges to
balance one's own your energy your
output and your input right these are
some of the things that just came up as
like where balance is a really helpful
term actually to describe to describe
that
[Music]
and it feels like it's been now brought
forth in so many different ways a yin
and yang just overtime of just the sort
of perfect harmonization of this reality
being at at play this reality becoming
alive this reality unfolding it just it
does it just it feels trying to put
symbols on it in itself is such a big
struggle but in a sense also that the
process of putting symbols on it is a
way to aim to hopefully architect the
next world future where there is less
suffering there is more flourishing
there's more prosperity that's a process
that I'm also just constantly trying to
figure out because it is so fast that we
say something and then we realized that
we've evolved and that we can't keep up
anymore funny we were sharing judges
reflecting with you to have you know
there's something shifting I'm sure a
lot of people are resonate with this er
just on the fast track of evolution as
so many of us are right now especially
like visionaries who are asking
questions about okay what is this new
earth like how are we architecting more
harmonious ways of being in the world
like what is the new story you know how
how are we gonna be showing up when you
know capitalism and this you know like
money centric way of doing and over
producing in lieu of also like
exhaustion and competition in comparison
all these things when that no longer is
a thing like how do we show up and we're
already sensing and tuning into this
being very close you know that were in
this fast track of our evolution and
what I notice is like a sensitivity
actually to wow how a lot of people are
not operating on that level and
sometimes it can feel to them like a
shock like I'll share with them what I'm
going through in my life and
like wait what like you just told me
like this was happening here this is
happening now what and they'll be
shocked but for me it's like you know a
month is like 20 years or something at
this rate and so I'm just noticing this
kind of awkward at times communication
challenge that will arise or it's like
oh wait I actually have to explain more
contacts to people such as like my
family in some cases or even friends you
know who are like not operating at that
same speed and also can't maybe fathom
how things could be processed that
quickly although we do all have the
capacity to heal to transform to move
through yea years in months and weeks
should we so choose the more that that I
tap into this oneness the more that it
feels perfect and
yeah and I'm really grateful to be able
to go back and forth with people on this
exact subject because the level of
abstraction that we are gifted in order
to formulate our consciousness to this
point to be able to talk about it in
itself is a beautiful gift that we were
given and now to be stewards of that
gift and to try and figure out how to
properly build a next world is I mean
you just spoke about it it's it's it's
quite radical to talk to people about a
future where the economic machinery is
not gripping onto people's throats and
it's not pushing unique snowflakes every
person being a unique instrument that's
being played in the symphony into
circular boxes like stamping people out
like like gingerbread cookies or like
pawns in the chess archetype or like the
soldiers in the risk board game
archetype that you're listening earlier
and so that's a radically different
world that it did that is not that it's
not this one but it's it's perfect
conceived out the evolutionary process I
I want to ask you this question when you
look at the ways of the when we when we
wrote specifically romanticize with
indigeneity albeit there were horrific
things that also happened but when we
romanticize with it we like to talk
about the deep feelings of
interconnectedness of in immediate
return hunter-gatherers the nomadic ones
that are deeply connected with each
other in their environment and there's
no excesses of resources there's no gray
area in society at there's deep respect
for women there's all this types of
things
deep deep music art story
does it feel as though those values have
not been evolving and Co harmonizing
with modernity today and that in a sense
that we are in the process of
remembering our species amnesia from the
photos grave feelings and trying to
figure out a move forward with some of
them I love the way you you've set that
up and the way that you see the way that
you see is really it's fun it's
different from the way I see so I
enjoyed that um yeah what comes up as I
hear you you know raise that question is
like immediately I was just like well
wait a minute like we've all been there
we've all been there like I like to just
tune in with you know what part of you
it was an indigenous person living at
that time many lifetimes maybe you know
I know that I have many experiences from
different time lines living an
indigenous community being a
hunter-gatherer one of them one thing I
specifically remembered actually what
feels important to share is because it
connects with the economic you know
capitalistic kind of deconditioning
we're in the midst of is you know one
time a long time ago and I was in my
Akashic records training like the first
training I ever did to learn about
Kaushik records and learning how to
channel and you know really share and
like shine and my gifts as an intuitive
healer and guide one of the exercises I
was practicing in was just like I was
dealing with so much scarcity in my
consciousness I was so struggling I was
like I was in a job that I really wasn't
happy in as I know so many people are
right now especially people that are
waking up they're like I'm just so
unhappy but I don't know what to do I'm
just I have to make money and I'm good
at this or it's easy or it could be fine
and you just kind of can settle was it
safe it's comfortable you know but I was
at this point of my journey where my
spirit was just like I really felt like
I was at my wits ends I was so full of
fear it was all about money it wasn't
really about money but that's what I
thought it was at the time
so one of the Akashic records and I
asked to be shown an aspect of me and
anyone can do this by the way it's like
a meditation practice you can just go
into meditative state and ask to be
shown a version of you or a past-life
version of you that was an expert in the
thing that you're wanting to come into
greater mastery over so for me in this
case it was okay show me an aspect of
myself or another timeline in which I
was a master of abundance and I was
shown this you know I was like looking
at a mirror at a version of me as a felt
like a chief like of a tribe it was
beautiful chief and like the plains you
know the mountains in the background and
I got to ask this guide you know hey
like what's the deal how do I get into
abundance I'm suffering I'm not happy
how can I be free what's in my way you
know how do i transcend this like
slavery and you know so profound cuz no
words were really spoken but there was
more this feeling like I was looking
into this person's eyes really into me
the one hmm the reflection and the
response I received was kind of this and
with a gesture of this you know like
look around you I was but it was just a
felt sensation and like a telepathic
communication no words it was just like
and kind of the sense of confusion
actually like what are you talking about
how could you possibly think that like
look around you look at everything
that's here like look at look at this
world and that hit me so deeply it was
like wow like it just it showed the
illusion of even buying into those kinds
of stories and beliefs and like the
emotions associated with them like wow
that's not even it doesn't even exist
in this reality actually like this is
the real world this is abundance like
look at this infinite expanse of the
earth and the land and like you know
multi-dimensional access to your
different aspects of self and you know
some profound so I just shared that for
some reason it
like an appropriate response to what
you're asking and maybe more my style
and I see the world yes but but to your
point like indigeneity you know like wow
there's so much wisdom there when we
were living with the land or a living in
nature I mean it's so healing you just
go listen honestly sometimes and I see
this in myself so much it's like so many
of the issues and problems and struggles
and you know these like existential
crises and like even envisioning the new
earth and how we're gonna build it and
you know the timeline it's like okay if
you actually just go into nature for
like a day and get off of the screen you
get off of your phone yes and actually
allow your body to do its natural
process of healing allowing your nervous
system to just rest which happens if you
just step outside of the city yes you
see it clearly you know and you can't
help but feel connected you can't help
but feel you know activated in your
senses and your intuition can't help but
hear your inner voice become amplified
and I think that goes for all humans you
know like all of us there's such
powerful healing and so imagine when we
were just living like that imagine we're
just living like that with no
obstruction you know just with the land
we can't help but be in harmony so yes I
think we're remembering that I really
loved your response there okay so I've
always been so fascinated with how I
don't want to loop this all the way back
switch you're initially saying but I'll
get there that we're now starting to use
this with these words of like nature
therapy people going to decrease
cortisol levels now we're scientifically
proving it well we can also aim to
understand the opposite as well trying
to map biometric states of people
outside of Metropolis or inside and when
you do look at the economic machineries
grips on people's nervous systems when
they're inside
of the machinery it's quite difficult to
UM feel these feelings of abundance and
that prosperity and these its
interconnectedness love it and like you
said when you go out and you go through
that process of more clearing your
channel and enabling that process of
oneness with in a more natural setting
it it's so wise it's so wise and
metropolis is in many ways are not ok
and then leading even further back in
that I really appreciate your take on it
which is that we haven't we probably
haven't talked about this enough on the
show to where it's probably so easy for
us to just kind of like move through it
without taking a little bit of time to
also explain it and talk about it so
what does it what does it actually mean
to be tapped into past lives and like
things like the Akashic s'right when
you're talking about things like a place
where everything that has ever been and
that could ever be is located and when
you're talking about things like you
actually were here during indigenous
times and you know how do people
especially like how much the scientific
method has gripped also our
understandings how how do you but while
there's also things like the Dalai Lama
and punch and Lama trying to constantly
go through a process of discovering
where is the next young one
where are they where's the next one
that's been rebirth and so there's like
that versus you know so right so it's
walk us through this this process of how
you even you yourself commune with that
truth and how you go back and identify
these past cells cetera so much there I
feel like great decoding the matrix
hahahaha here you are hmm
could you imagine that we're all like so
powerful you know to exist beyond time
and to exist beyond any linear confines
of even space or even a body which is
another way I would answer like we are
all one you know so I love the Akashic
records as a modality to tune into that
state of being on a regular basis
because that to me feels much more real
let's say those one more time we're so
powerful that we're beyond could you
imagine that we are all so powerful that
we actually exist beyond the confines of
time and space and even beyond a body
beyond any like linear physical confines
you know so much of our reality
machinery as you say is like really
predicated on this collective agreement
you know collective asleep Ness you know
that says X Y Z you know confined
limited potential a lot of control and a
lot of fear therein and for me what
feels more true is well actually we're
all you know completely infinite in our
capacity to access any information at
any time we have access to all that all
that ever is all that ever was all to
ever will be and you know another way to
think of the Akashic records is the
known field just a simple understanding
and knowing that you know where energy
beings we're actually not like a
personality not at you go I'm not even
this body you know I'm energy and I have
a unique energetic signature like a
snowflake you know I have a really
unique signature
energy I'm immortal not matter there's
energy you know and and so I get excited
about like making this life about like
really exploring
you know our individual energetic
signature when starting to interact also
more you know explicitly more
intentionally with with our lives with
each other with the world as like this
energetic experience of okay wait we're
in this known field something shifts
when you and I meet ray and there's just
the subtle energetic communication
that's frankly far more effective far
more instantaneous than anything you or
I are even saying because our energetic
body emotional body is processing so
much faster and it's processing so much
more you know like there's so much
communication happening so I love to
just make that explicit like okay yeah
you have an energy field I have an
energy field when we come together we
create this new kind of a field and we
tend to be you know right now we're in
resonance so we're kind of like we're
vibing or sharing we're flowing and then
there's even this bigger thing called
the known field which is like the
collective fields right it's like every
I mean all living beings some would even
say like all of the entities that exist
and all of the multiverses and even
beyond anything that I'm consciously
aware of in this moment you know and
like wait a minute if you and I are
connected energetically in this field we
could imagine expanding out to connect
with you know the consciousness of the
city the country even beyond earth and
in an instant we're suddenly connected
to the Akashic field or the non field of
everything you know and it's just a
simple practice to like expand your
awareness and just it's another game
it's like a new way to play you know
like well wait a minute if I have access
to any answer any reflection any support
you know with maybe this whole team of
guides different supporting energies
whatever you believe in you know but I'm
showing again and again that we have we
each have this like stadium full of
supporting spirits and different aspects
of ourselves that are just they're ready
like waiting to give us guidance in fact
really want to give us guidance if only
we would listen and ask for it
yeah beyond space-time in the body if we
believe that that is where the power is
at then doing things like going beyond
our body into this field of another
which empathy really is something that's
that in a sense it's beyond your body
when your cap when you're able to feel
what another person is feeling then
going beyond that to the feelings of the
city the feelings of the planet the
feelings of all that is that if you can
go there if you can go into what have
been past lives if you can go into what
is then it does it not then also say
that you then feel the future all the
possible future states that the
trajectory can go into yeah because I
mean if there's no time to what extent
has you know all of the all of the
future potentials
this might sound really funny to save it
as what it feels those to be true it's
like to an extent like if we can think
about something like even as a future
conjecture a possibility like doesn't
that kind of mean it's already happened
and so like on some level because how
about I be tuning in with that idea if
it has it on some level already occurred
you know and some other reality or some
other I mean more and more I love that
show also the Oh a I feel like have you
seen that show again well my what is it
again it's it's this brilliant show that
I've literally have never seen something
like so accurately depict you know
multi-dimensional consciousness and like
parallel universes parallel realities
parallel timelines and it's just genius
it's so good
is there frequently going between that's
Rick and Morty does a little bit of that
as well jumping between
the meep multiverse or however people
want to describe it I haven't seen that
one it's an animated one I just love I
love all of these you know resources
that we have available right now that
are so encoded with Ascension there so
they're just showing they're giving us
so much permission to explore these you
know new avenues through which we can
better perceive and understand ourselves
and really come into more of our power I
mean that's what all of this about that
this is about I feel like an ascension
it's like where am I able to really
source more of my power more of my
innate you know my creatorship
you know like it's like awakening to
what it is that you're really here to
create what you're really capable of
creating beyond any perceived confines
or limitations you know especially when
it comes to the future like okay what I
find to be really exciting and also
challenging when thinking about when
tuning in with when allowing right the
vision of the future the more beautiful
world we know is possible than where the
story that we want to live into the new
agreements and new rules of engagement
form our harmonious world it's like wow
that's when you see all the conditioning
come up around like wow where have I
been operating in a box where have I
been holding judgment against how I
think people are gonna show up you know
there's like wow and that's in that
process of being and truly open you know
inquiry about really new ways of being
to get there on earth it's like there's
a lot of emotion I find there's a lot of
emotional a lot of behavioral healing
actually in conditioning that
deconditioning that is required to
actually be able to see clearly how we
might play together a newest whoa okay
so I have so many questions about of
being able to go back I feel like
everyone's heard about past life yeah
let's let's do that keep applying that
but I'm actually not why am I not it's
let's do that in that I'll remember
where I want
let's do that so again to this point of
their being noted I may also just say
that because we by doing this explaining
this by maybe catalyzing other people to
try themselves to also dive back like
that it does it just feels like we have
the power of you know Tom we have a time
machine we have this ability to kind of
go back and just to dive in and feel
what was there feel what was there feel
what was there and if we can do that we
can really start drawing on some of the
things that are our consciousness may
have had you know really strong ideas
and wisdom with that is maybe not
present today yet I was wanting to be
remembered it is always present because
it's always here but are we not what are
we not paying attention to what are we
not listening to what are we not willing
to receive you know and so again it's
just I guess through one lens I can see
how a lot of people just write it off
like past lives whatever like I have one
of I believe in science and science ISM
is incredible I'm so grateful for
science Wow like thank you for allowing
me to understand more about my like
neuro chemistry and like biomechanic
like how to operate within a body I'm
here on earth to live in a body and like
take care of my body and feel great and
learn about my energy and become
masterful and like being fully present
you know and so science is great give us
this podcast yeah and we love it and we
love it so much and there's also so much
maybe more that like you know for me
especially like will never fit into the
lens of something measurable something
you know like quantifiable it's like the
infinite Ness the infinite like oneness
how do we measure that
like I don't it like for me that doesn't
quite compute within the lens of like
rationality science you know just trying
to measure and quantify put things in
boxes categorize there's like this
infinite there's such an infinite supply
infinite abundance of all of this other
wisdom that frankly has a you know you
mentioned the Dalai Lama and like I
think you implied some other very
ancient traditions
by the way like a lot of the history
that most people are operating you know
from the context in which we learned
about history is also very confined
there's actually like so much more
history on earth that is not taught in
any schools it's not really taught yes
if you think about what we've
archaeologically undiscovered it's
probably less than a percent of the
total I needed beyond that like again so
another another fun research for going
into the Akashic records and just being
open listen this whole conversation
about past lives is an invitation
especially for those who are more
scientifically minded and really like
but wait I like the numbers and I like
the research and I like the facts and I
you know could you imagine like could
you be open would you be willing to be
open to a new experience of your own
power of your own perception of your own
sensitivity of your own heart really
like of your own feelings maybe
surprising yourself with what might be
in there with might be what might be
available when you start to just just
open a little bit and even just you know
I was interviewing someone earlier today
his um his name's Dawson Church he wrote
mind over matter but and he's a you know
PhD researcher and talks all about the
neuro chemistry of the brain meditation
but and it's very like no spirituality
it's just like very practical it's like
very accessible practical technique to
get into a bliss state you know nothing
spiritual about that and I really
appreciate I really appreciate that I
appreciate that right now and all the
people that really embody being bridges
right being bridges because we we
require a lot of bridges right now but I
would just encourage like just for fun
in the spirit of practicality imagining
how practical it is to just you know
play in this new reality in which you
have a whole stadium full of like the
top advisers just like you could have a
board of advisers for your company for
your and but you know your investors etc
it's like imagine each and every one of
us has a whole board of advisers
existing in all sorts of different you
know different planes and dimensions
they've lived all these great life
experiences it's like your whole team of
mentors for all of the very precise
areas of mastery and expertise that you
would you
require on your path this is another way
to think of your past lives this is
another way of actually starting to look
to yourself as your own guide which I'm
really excited about as we see the like
guru dynamic totally fall apart in our
society it's like how do you get to be
your own guide how do you start to trust
yourself how do you start to go to
yourself for your own wisdom for your
own knowing trusting again that you have
so much power you have so much wisdom
and whether or not you believe that
you've lived in other lifetimes or even
car nated another experiences it's like
just try it on and see how it feels like
maybe you think about it as you know oh
you have different personalities you
have different identities that you play
with now like think about how you show
up in different environments and
communities those are all sorts of
different you know identities and then
have fun with personifying those more
explicitly and starting to actually
enter play and your own inner dialogue
or meditation just like I demonstrated
earlier like just for fun I mean Dawson
reminded me today that you know Napoleon
Hill who wrote the Think and Grow Rich
talks about this same thing in his book
from like the 1930s
you know imagining that was like one of
the most foremost you know books on
prolific books on you know actually a
lot about capitalism right and really
being an entrepreneur and being really
being successful and he talks about
having your imaginary council your Board
of Advisors you know imagining yourself
surrounded by you know all the people
that you look up to most and I love that
too but I also like to include you know
why not look up to yourself and like
your future self could be in there yeah
or you know the version of you that at
some level at some time past present or
future has been an expert in abundance
and intimacy in channeling and whatever
you want you know and that's and that's
how we actually start to create the new
the new rules for how we play in the
game of our lives
your own personal experiences with ego
loss or ego death or interconnectedness
or unconditional love.what have those
been hmm it's a continual ongoing
process with the no end yeah and I'll
share what's absolutely just most
present for me right now
hmm
I'm in a process right now you know and
this and I'm always in process I guess
we're always evolving always in process
but right now particularly feels like a
tender moment in which it has been
revealed to me they're a very intimate
business partnership actually that's
felt very much to be like as a deeply
intimate almost like a romantic dynamic
without the romance but it's like
brought up so much unconsciousness as
all great relationships are designed to
do and yeah stretching my capacity just
to be with the parts of me that feel
really ashamed and humiliated even you
know by how I've actually held myself to
such an impossible standard of
perfection and how I've been very
judgmental and critical and frankly
really mean to myself for a very long
time and this is not a new pattern this
is not a new awareness what was
surprising and what did feel new and
really revealing was like just having a
deeper layer of this experience really
illuminated by this particular person's
energy just in their presence in their
presence something happens where I'm
really still in this process of like I'm
not sure what's gonna happen because
part of me was like I just want to leave
I just want to be done this is so
uncomfortable this is so painful that's
the ego right getting was the ego death
it's like I'm gonna die so part of me is
like I don't want to die like things
were okay as long as I'm not feeling
that stuff you can just keep going over
here and kind of compare
that's an aspect right but then the true
the true self my heart is like no it's
time to let that part die it's time to
let that story die it's time to let that
behavior die Wow that thing that I was
actually really hiding from everyone
that way that I'm so I can be really
mean to myself and have a lot of talk
about unconditional love there's a lot
of ways in which my self love is very
conditional and very dependent on how I
produce and how I perform and what I do
and how I'm seeing and what my image is
and like again nothing new there but
it's been painful to see how even with
all the healing and transformation I've
undergone and continue to commit commit
myself to there's just a deeper layer a
deeper layer like well like I've been
found out like this person sees how I've
been operating like in the shadows where
no one else would ever know or see this
person can see and that is revealing and
really for me feels very humiliating and
then I don't even want to be around that
person because it just feels like
everything I know all the ways I would
coach someone or do healing work with
someone to help them out of that I like
so humbled I'm like I don't know what to
do I can't give myself my own advice cuz
I just like kind of lock up I was trying
to communicate with this person
yesterday and this is someone I love
it's funny I sit like this person
because I have so much I have a lot of
resistance in my system right now you
know regarding this relationship but the
truth is there's love there the truth is
we've been brought together to do some
very powerful work and the truth is I
can't really get away with like running
away from this and just trying to
compartmentalize that doesn't work so to
answer your question I'm like really
feeling deeply humbled in this moment by
how much I've known and have learned and
taught and and still like wow I don't
actually I'm in a real unknown right now
it's like I'm not sure what's gonna
happen I'm not sure how I'm gonna show
up I know how to take care of myself
right now and how to like be soft and be
present but there's feels really massive
I feel like I've uncovered and like
Mount Everest blind spot
justice damn but it really feels like
that and I'm like okay [ __ ] like I have
to climb up this mountain because it
feels like it's the other side is a
major break their major freedom major
major newness you know but it's scary
reminds me also of the ignorance that is
just attached like a Mount Everest our
ankle and that we're trying to learn and
finish at the but the boulder hmm
and the what what he's laid out from the
moment that we're born and even before
that with ancestral lineage that's laid
out in these formative neural
architectures and that then is
constantly brought up at later moments
in our lives if we do not in a sense
become aware radically aware and
symbiotic with it it can come up like
volcanoes in our lives and I'm glad I'm
glad you point that out another thing
that I think would be helpful here is
that if you can kind of give us a a
breakdown of how you empathize because
the better that we can get behind
someone's perspective the more we can
also feel oneness and so yeah give us
that breakdown yeah well I think we were
pointing at two is like the distinction
between empathy and being empathetic or
empathic actually I should know this
empathetic versus empathic right there's
a distinction so being empathetic or
feeling empathy would mean like Oh
sad okay yeah I can understand how you
feel sad and that makes sense and it's
kind of a more intellectual experience
actually like oh yeah I'm sorry but then
you can leave and kind of feel like okay
that hope they're gonna be okay I'll go
into my life and you're you know maybe
not still feeling sad you're still
feeling like someone else's you know sad
experience actually happened to you so
that's the distinction between being
empathetic and then being an empath
which is maybe just a more heightened
attunement to the experience of empathy
being an empath and what I really have
experienced my whole life a lot of my
life I didn't understand this is what
was happening but you know being a nun
path means you actually can feel and
this is expressed different ways and by
different people everybody actually has
a different expression of this but it's
like I can actually feel how you are
feeling and how energy is moving in your
body and emotional experiences and
sometimes even you know then we get into
the psychic terrain of like thoughts and
memories and our body sensations and and
that's something I believe we all have
the capacity to attune or finally to is
this like very heightened empathic
experience where we can not only
intellectually understand why someone
feels and understands things the way
that they do but we can actually really
feel it as though it's our own
experience as the one you know and and
there's a there's a mastery and a
practice in in discerning you know your
experience from that of another's but
then being able to consciously choose
when to attune with someone else at that
level you know usually for the aim of of
healing that's usually why you know it's
always available to us is like to
support healing and growth and deeper
understanding
being tapped in tuned into the one on a
moment-to-moment level is being empathic
[Music]
interesting I wouldn't think of it like
that
but I guess that works I like that yeah
okay let's talk about how the the more
that someone has done this process of
self work the more that they can achieve
their life purpose and what has been
both your experience with your own self
work and achieving your life purpose and
also with helping other people what are
the most common roadblocks that people
are going through with trying to anchor
their divine mission into their life
asking you this because I again with
everything I've lived you know like I'm
also in this inquiry myself and another
deeper layer is being revealed of like
divine mission like getting really
specific and really clear on what feels
best for me instead of in the past what
has felt like a service servitude or an
obligation or something that is expected
from others so those are main roadblocks
I would say you know that most people
face and especially visionaries and
people really call I think I could
everybody you know but like people that
are at the forefront of kind of this
this visionary holding this visionary
energy of like I'm here to build a
better world I'm here to like build it
and I know that I have an important
mission on this planet to be of service
in a massive way you know and what are
the things that usually get in the way
of that being realized and there is like
nothing's in the way but what are a lot
of that what are the typical lessons
that emerge on that path really as a way
to help you reorient to your clear focus
that's how it would actually rephrase
that because there's no blocks
there's no blocks there's just there's
you know there's moments on the path
that are there to help you refocus and
realign usually through the experience
of contrast but nothing's in your way
like nothing's nothing's in the way
nothing's blocking you how long you
decide to stay in one of these moments
is
up to you and you know that might last a
long time depending on how willing you
are to let go of an old story you're old
you know fear whatever it is for you and
the main moments or challenges that
arise are yeah like people-pleasing
doing the thing that you know that will
make everybody how that you think at
some level make everybody happy the
thing that people are expecting of you
the thing that you're just good at just
settling right because you're a lot of
us are like really good at a lot of
things that we could just go do that
especially oh I see all these other
people doing that thing right so giving
your power away out of what you see
other people doing successfully and
maybe overly identifying with people
that you maybe put on a pedestal and
wanting to be them and misplacing
yourself and their identity and their
purpose being disconnected from yourself
you know getting chasing you no money or
again attention validation it's kind of
the same thing just chasing attention
chasing energy you know instead of
operating from this really all of these
these challenges can be met with a
recommitment and really a resilience but
a recommitment to returning to one
Center and getting root that sounds
silly as I said that this is like this
evolution that I'm in I'm like that's on
silly what do I really mean yeah yes all
these challenges can be met with it's
actually like a discipline like that's
what comes up it's like hmm the path of
living your purpose demands discipline
yeah it's not like this like yeah I'm
gonna live my purpose I just meditate
and [ __ ] it's like no it requires
discipline and mastery and I wish
someone had told me this a long time ago
you know like discipline like to be
attuning yourself to being grounded to
being stable to being present to
listening to having your energy and your
power contained in your sense of Center
you know so that you hear your guidance
you feel your guidance you know what is
right for you you
you're meant to show up it actually
strikes me as funny that this is
something we would even explain or
reason our way into or out of because
it's so natural like we're each born as
this unique snowflake as as unique you
know transmission of a being there's a
human body here to share something
powerful and a very unique expression
you should every one of us there's no
competition there's no compare but why
would you ever compare yourself to
anybody else right this is something I
say to myself frequently but it's like
really tuned into that there's no
comparison when you're actually focused
on not even doing what you think you
should do or your purpose there's no
thinking it's like are you allowing
yourself to follow the creative impulse
that naturally flows through you that's
naturally guiding you to be of service
it's naturally guiding you to help it's
naturally guiding you to contribute it's
this whole bigger puzzle you know that
we're all a part of that when we
actually listen to our own individual
impulse it's like somehow we work really
harmless like nature somehow there's a
job for everyone somehow there's a
unique place in which every single
person belongs but the issue that you
know we're evolving out of I hope soon
and I really like well okay I have a lot
of compassion it's like one of the
issues is like too many cooks in the
kitchen like too many people trying to
do the same thing and no one doing their
thing their unique thing well so
discipline right and cultivating mastery
over like what it is that you love most
what is that turns you on most about
life what it is that it's like every
single person comes to you with the same
question you like these things are
obvious your purpose is so obvious it's
right there like everyone around you can
usually name it and see it before you
can but the issue again is you know
those of us who feel like we're not an
alignment yet it's like we're still
looking out here for someone else to
give us the answer there's someone else
to like give us the permission to do the
thing that we actually already know when
we follow our impulses like oh it's so
simple it's so easy I mean I can get out
of it what's that thing I love like get
out of the way of being who you truly
are like just get out of the way of
being who you already are
you know but simply put discipline
grounding and centering practice
cultivating observation of oneself
making your unconsciousness conscious
you know being willing to look at that
stuff as it comes up because it can be
really scary and really confronting and
humiliating and and all the stuff but
are you willing to let those false
aspects of yourself go so that more of
who you already are who you really are
can simply arise yeah your focus on
discipline on the North Star the
discipline of this what's in the unique
DNA of the cedar of the snowflake or the
instrument as part of the symphony
that's being played yeah that is that is
a top principle that's a top principle
if not maybe even the top principle well
you know the thing is so odyssey is
something that came through actually at
the end of last year and it's something
I brought through and then have now
built with a team and with a partner you
know the business partner I mentioned
this beautiful reflection challenging my
soul growth and an odyssey is is this is
this invitation for leaders new earth
architects of people that are like
really called who are already in some
way building the new earth right who are
already like running companies and and
being of service and have done a lot of
personal work I've come into great
mastery over their energy like are
they're living their purpose right and
they're kind of like okay now what like
I've done a lot of the things what's
next and what I feel is what's like what
is next is okay let's get all of those
masters and visionaries in a room
together and let's actually get more
clear on like what is my unique key
what's your unique key cuz we've all
been doing like 20 different things that
were really good at cuz we're brilliant
we're really brilliant beings and we've
been doing a lot of work but what's like
my actually unique key that I have for
this
than on earth more beautiful world
puzzle like what's the unique one thing
a specific mastery that I bring when I
know that you're showing up in your
mastery bringing your key and I no
longer have to do that job you know
what wants to arise through me and so
that's like a curiosity that I'm in
right now is like how do we create more
spaces like that and that's you know
part of what Odyssey is answering is
like creating space for us to gather and
get more clear because it's only a
reflection that I can see myself as the
one it's only in your reflection that I
can see myself I can't actually see
myself I can't I made you to see myself
and so it's only in a reflection that I
can get clear on okay what is my purpose
I've been living my purpose I've been
serving my mission but I require greater
clarity like I want to know like what is
my key what's like my unique mission I
want to get specific you know that's
what we require and building this new
earth we require great specificity
excellence and to excavate this requires
discipline right to come into that
mastery and kind of that again like
beginner's mind actually is like great
mastery right like are you willing to
let go of everything you thought you
knew everything you've learned
everything you've been conditioned to
how you've been conditioned to operate
to actually say well wait a minute okay
what is the thing that I really like I'm
open right now what is it that I'm
really here to serve you know what is it
that I'm really here to contribute and
what feels best and and that's what I
really believe is a guiding principle
for this new earth is like leading with
what feels good as our bodies become
more highly attuned instruments truth to
abundance connection to the infinite you
know kind of connection within us all to
humanity to this being a big family you
know what feels right what feels good
not what looks good not what we think
would make sense because that's when
we're operating in a confined limited
frame instead of like you know how
infinite possibility something totally
new you know big ideas that's the space
that I feel we're called to play in more
mars-like leading with feeling leading
with our intuitive sensibility leading
more with our multidimensionality you
know love the keys hmm the different
players of different instruments the
puzzle pieces the DNA that's in every
one of the seeds that's flowering big
trees filled with fruits that as as the
next world comes in that the economic
machinery decreases its grip and gets
augmented to where the play and the love
the being the music the art the
expression and even the science are just
all more prosperous what I really want
is and what I feel called to create like
this is my prayer for Odyssey and like
the other communities that will be
birthed from Odyssey because it's really
an incubator of community and like other
organizations that would be birthed from
the space of leading with you know
coherence and collaboration and like
real embodied a leadership you know and
what I really crave is just more space
for you know where permission is granted
for people to be there just like to be
who they really are and to be expressed
in their their gifts to feel safe you
know to be a CEO to be an impact
investor to be like a you know like
showing up in the very third dimensional
reality but then to come into a space
with fellow leaders and to feel really
safe to
yeah like I see energy and I work with
energy medicine and I channel ETS and I
or whatever it is anything all of the
infinite unique expressions are very
intuition are welcome do you ever feel
like the side of spirituality
occasionally wanders into snake oil and
then science aims to help it not wander
into snake oil I like that question and
then part of me is like what is snake
oil but I understand it's like the
larger it's like the context of that
story where someone was like misled and
it's like the whole yeah there's a lot
of like ridiculousness and like people
have profited of you know what do you
call it spiritual materialism
illusionary spirituality like there's
huge industries that have been created
you know psychic like fake psychics on
every corner in LA and like or who knows
real or fake you don't really know
anymore because there's just an
oversaturation same thing is true for
coaches you know like the coaching
industry or just watching that video of
like making fun of all the different
kinds of coaches that there are and like
everyone's a coach it's just over like
how are we operating when it's like the
things that were once and Charles Ian
talks a lot about this like you know the
like commodification of all that is
sacred yep
you know and then we are just like
confused like what's real yeah but you
know what's real by guess what if you're
in your mastery and discipline of like
being connected to yourself you know
that's real there's nothing to protect
from there's no snake oil there's no or
maybe you go choose to have that
experience because you're just curious
about what it's like to be in the
contrast of an illusion or someone
profiting off of you know a false
persona and I don't know if there's a
right or wrong because even the people
that I've experienced you were totally
you know at some level is not everybody
doing the best they can even if they are
like they do have an agenda to sell
snake oil or rip people off or you know
they're profiting off of this false
identity false marketing like but maybe
they're serving a purpose and the
greater scheme of things is that person
that we would think is a swindler not
serving some purpose at some level for
someone to
some kind of a meaningful healing
experience otherwise it wouldn't be
happening and similarly can be said
about how science may wander itself into
nuclear bombs and then spirituality can
be like what the [ __ ] are you doing well
here we are at the balance again the
balance of the skills and I'm excited
about this moment we're in right now
where more and more there's just Brit
bridging happening there's no black and
white there's no science and
spirituality you know I mean as I say
that I just kind of laugh like wait a
minute like science is inherently very
spirit like it reminds me the interview
earlier today where the guys like it's
very practical I get is talking to me in
a encoded message so many of these
scientists are actually like total
Mystics you know and they're like but I
have this methodology for the meditation
it's just very practical it's based in
neuroscience it's just mechanical but
his energy is saying like and I'm gonna
wake all of you up but he would never
say that or it's like one of my teachers
that I studied with marc bolan who
teaches all about family constellations
and inherited family trauma and like
doing really deep it's like very
shamanic healing work like having
full-body sensations of like I would
imagine as though you were at an
ayahuasca ceremony without any medicine
just doing you know embodied trauma
therapy and having like deep somatic
healing experiences this guy he would
never say I wanted to interview him to
about being an empath because he was a
super empath super psychic empath and
total shaman but he would never call
himself those things and he's like no
you will not interview me about being an
empath because I do not use that
language because he doesn't want to
isolate all of the people that are in
this kind of scientific self-proclaim
kind of scientific camp who maybe feel
this is a deep conditioning right that
there's an aversion just even our
language some of our language can be
encoded as like an aversion can be
encoded with like mistrust as snake-oil
as lacking credibility as really like
just having its power totally diminished
and so that's that's something I having
inquiry and explanation you know
exploration about like okay wait a
minute to what extent of some of my
language turning people off who
otherwise maybe I could be supporting or
I could be connecting with you know but
as long as we're responsible for our
truth and speaking from the truth and
even if it's awkward and we correct
ourselves because what I just said
doesn't make sense anymore as long as
we're speaking from the truth there's
not so much of that management that
needs to happen there's not so much
there's no perception management there's
no there's no there's not a lot of
thought needed actually you know so
that's just something I want to really
anchor in in my and myself because
that's something I'm I'm working on
right now and it feels you know it
speaks to the like obligation servitude
dynamic of like really wanting to help
like wanting to awaken wanting to serve
but then that desire which is a really
beautiful intention can sometimes get
you know colored with yeah just being
distracted from the point and not really
yeah I had the experience just now as I
was speaking that what I was saying
stopped being relevant and stopped
feeling authentic and so my thought just
completed yeah that happens to me a lot
as well it's awkward right but it's just
so important to name it it's a name it
it's like I just played out some old
well sometimes our mind like I think
that was an experience of the mind
trying to catch up with like a much
faster processing that's happening
energetically and so I caught myself
like latching on to some old story I'm
trying to like one give it one last
hurrah it's like no that's complete yeah
[Laughter]
earlier when you described how we talk
about how everything is won and then we
kind of showcase some sort of a within
this one there is some sort of a classic
example of a of a dualism of like good
and evil or how are the yin and yang
however this balance that gets struck in
the process of the one evolving over
time and that it's constantly in perfect
flux as it evolves to me it is in
perfect flux a science and spirit way of
viewing it or good and evil way of
viewing it in whatever way yet it feels
as though that if they understand one
another better I want to work on the
understanding one another better side
but under but misunderstanding one
another will catch up at approximately
the same pace as understanding them
better and so that's why it's perfect
because it happens that way and I think
actually probably one of the most
perfect ways of viewing it is just take
like any social media platform because a
social media platform is like the
perfect balance of good and evil it has
all of the incredible qualities of being
able to communicate profound wisdom
across the planet at lightning speeds
but it also has the problem of the
business plans of the attention
economics and advertising models the
cancerous comparison mentalities that
affect our our suicide rates and our
mental health and well-being so that's
those are kind of really interesting
ways to look at that so it's like almost
as though as some sort of a we'd like
solve something and we make something
upgrade it towards good that we say
there is also something that comes up
that is it's almost like this also like
this too
nuclei problem a believe around 1953 or
so where there was just that the
cracking into the atom gives us both the
power to to do incredible things like
understand what's actually going on at a
at a level of a particle in the universe
yet it also makes a nuclear bomb
possible same with the cell that you can
understand like the how what what DNA
plays the way that DNA plays out in a
cell and in our lives yet it also gives
you the potential to create absolute
catastrophic engineering of malevolence
as in biology so you you kind of you
kind of get this this this good and evil
balance on in all these different
categories within the reality that I'm
aiming to try and steward the good ones
albeit there are it's almost as though
there's always going to be eat I it may
be such a it may be such a perfect
creation this reality that there will
always be are a harmonization of flux of
those as as it goes on how do you feel
about about you just take me on a
journey my friend do I feel about that
Wow well the question more questions
right so like to what extent is good or
bad or good or evil it's like this feel
like judgements and projections and I
don't think those are absolute truths so
that's one curiosity to what extent is
that like cuz to you something that you
think is good I might not think is good
I might think that's bad and then you
know there's just that whole whole game
implicit in that also reminds me of the
law there's like energy dynamics right
of like energy is neither created nor
destroyed and so if we're
well that arose I don't know why and
then also like the the again the scales
and balance energy exchange like taking
something means you know eventually you
must give it back you must repay huh I'm
just really tuning in more with that
like for every what I also heard you say
is with every you know possible you
don't really think about actually just
the dynamic of light and dark right so
that's something we can all agree on it
was like in duality we have this you
know sense of light maybe that's more of
the way that I resonate with
understanding the good and evil good or
bad or whatever it's like light and dark
and light we might think of as you know
our true self our gifts our purpose or
you know can I tell you why light and
dark we I stopped saying as much oh I
stopped saying it as much because of the
whole skin color thing I thought that we
we had some conversations on the
programs on stain it started driving me
nuts how darkness and dark skin color
and people are trying to move towards
light skin color and yeah so that kind
of things started driving me like in so
any that's why I started using lis good
and bad or good even so funny to me how
do you hear me good and bad or evil
feels way more like controversial go
later dark and I would have never
thought of the color thing ever
yeah but I guess yeah I mean I could see
how people might be sensitive to that
but uh no truer reaction is like I have
no idea how they would connect this yeah
good good good so then maybe it can
continue if we can evolve past that way
to look at like personal development and
like your self as a whole listen part of
arriving into the consciousness unit
what we're talking about is unity
consciousness right like the one
realization that there's no me without
you I see myself in your reflection I'm
here to be on earth to like master
really being in relationship so that I
can better see and understand myself and
arrive into more true and more of like
the wholeness remembering more of my
wholeness remembering more of my power
remember
more of my innate infinite wisdom
remembering my divinity remembering that
I'm God
you know actually whoa okay now what do
we want to create you know and so the
light on the dark is helpful actually
for understanding this journey to
wholeness right journey and remembering
one's wholeness it's like oh the light
would contain it but the shadow and the
light actually contain talk about keys
right all the same keys there's like a
light and a shadow side like all these
different dynamics that will come across
in our lives like our purpose our
relationships our you know all the
different aspects of our life and how we
express ourselves in this reality it's
like you know another way I would just
define light and dark or light and
shadow like I you said light and shadow
yeah like right shadow yeah like light
what is illuminated what we're willing
to just be seen as what we're willing to
like put forth like Here I am here's my
image and then shadow like as I was
describing earlier the things that were
hiding the things that were ashamed the
things that were in contraction about
versus expansion so that's another fun
way just another law universal law of
like how we're operating as energetic
beings on earth and then the multiverse
is like expanding or contributing and
then we come back to decisions we come
back to choice to come back to the rules
of the game that we're deciding to play
yeah and then we're we're not judging
things as good or bad or wrong or right
because those aren't absolute truths
those are just like judgments but what I
do know is oh I have this choice maybe
that's all I ever have and is it
expensive is it bringing me into more
illumination is it bringing me into more
you know truth unity connection or not
or not yeah
or is it the opposite of all of those
things and so that's a different way
that I would like riff on what you kind
of brought up is like and that's a
helpful tool because at any moment in
your life it's like okay orient yourself
to what you truly value and what are you
here for you can decide to redesign that
at any moment if it doesn't feel good
anymore what do you value why are you
here you decide that that's not some
external thing like what am i here I
need to find my purpose
decide wire here what do you want to be
experiencing what do you want to feel
what do you value what do you stand for
you know and then and then you have more
of a compass when your choices are
emerging okay
does this feel expensive does this feel
an alignment with my values does this
get me closer to where I want to be you
know or not I like that way of putting
it it is expansive versus contractive or
like that way like the light versus
shadow these are these are helpful they
are in another part of it is kind of
like the feeling of an in harmony zation
between an intuition and a rationality
as well as another way of putting it
yeah you can see that yeah the
spirituality and science harmonization
that they're in this perfect flux and
it's a joy to be on the ride and that's
something so important to communicate
and fall in love with and if one can I
don't know if one can do their best to
stay on the ride of joy and what I'm
curious what you think about this whole
thing of the wheel of emotion I and also
I'm curious about mirrors with you I
know myself because I have you here and
that you reflect me and that some of the
things you say which you look you would
never say but if you were to say things
that I knew were like that I but I
shouldn't go and do something violent it
said
I should not listen to that mirror
mm-hmm but once around
maybe waste augment my life I should
listen to and so there's discernment
mm-hmm in the mirrors right so I'm
curious about that and also I'm curious
about the emotional thing like you come
to me with anger I don't I don't really
care like I don't care for maybe being
an empathic to diving into that maybe I
want to stay joyful and I don't want to
take that on so how do you how do you
feel about those communicate with like
such simplicity but it's like those are
long topics Veronese and maybe not maybe
exactly not so long you know
listen discernment Oh discipline okay we
practice energy mastery coming into our
Center coming into resting like
stillness that we can observe what's
occurring instead of being reactive and
like impulsive and when you're you know
able to hold kind of a stable resting
Stillpoint disturb that happens pretty
naturally for a lot of my life that
wasn't always the case at all for most
of my life I was like living in a lot of
reactivity I think most people are it's
like reactivity just like instant like
feedback react feedback react not a lot
of thought not a lot of observation not
a lot of mindfulness not a lot of
presents a lot of just like what I think
I should be doing so I'll just do that
and operating kind of in this like you
know conveyor belt factory mentality as
you said earlier and it really does feel
like that in a lot of cases a lot of
behavioral you know conditioning there
and um so just certainement you know wow
I mean I learned to serve it through
pain frankly like that's been the
journey for a long time has been like
arriving to an awareness that greater
discernment must be cultivated only
through discomfort and pain right like
think that's how we how we grow and
transform although later on you know as
the path continues I should hope that it
doesn't have to be so painful anymore
and with more examples of people sharing
their pain and transformation maybe
other people don't have to go through
the similar depths of pain and suffering
and whatnot to learn the same lessons
and faster and sooner and so yeah when
it all comes back again to like being a
really finely attuned barometer for
truth what your body is when you're
taking care of when your self sourcing
all of your needs when you are
unconditionally loving yourself you know
it's the best of your ability when
you're embodying that sense of wholeness
and completeness and it's complex though
even as I talk about this I'm like but
then they have to do the inner child
work on the inner parenting work and the
heal the family trauma and and also we
can exist in a reality where no in this
moment I'm free I'm sovereign I'm a
whole and complete and I choose to be
attuned to happiness and joy and in this
present moment I am that and so it is so
again simultaneous experience is all
happening in the same moment you know my
journey has been a longer one of like a
lot of steps and a lot of work and a lot
of different dimensions of the healing
and now I'm excited to see more and more
available to us this like kind of
instantaneous almost like flipping a
switch like how do you want to feel like
you're at that power closer right how do
you want to feel choose how you want to
feel right now like choose it embody it
be it don't engage in the mind that's
gonna want to keep you in the survival
fear fighter Flay as your nervous system
becomes route patterned don't do that go
into an energetic movement singing like
the self care practice something that
gets you into a good feeling state and
just give yourself what you need right
now do we need to know hate to know love
[Music]
I don't know shoes maybe
yeah for me and again pointed to the
like the concept of like choosing each
each and every one of us choosing our
own game right to come here to deeply
understand maybe even come into mastery
over a particular theme for me my life
lesson is is unconditional love I would
say and so yeah I've selected a lot of
lessons and continue to lessons and
triggers and painful situations and
growing edges I choose them again and
again these situations that reflect to
me the opposite of unconditional love so
that I can refine my discernment
awareness understanding of what
unconditional love actually is it might
be something that I never fully master
understand but just keep peeling away
the layers and peeling away the
distortions and coming into a greater
understanding and I want to ask you what
do you feel if you resonate with what I
just shared do you feel that like you
have an awareness of your lesson or have
you thought about this like your mastery
lesson or like maybe one of the central
themes that you're here in this life to
really come into deep relationship with
an understanding of the nature of this
reality what is the nature of this
reality why it's here how we all partake
in it and its beauty
and being in constant aw of that beauty
and trying to share that beauty which is
what any good artist tries to do do you
think everyone's an artist I do I do
every seed or every snowflake or every
instrument that's being played out in
the symphony is on piece of art and
every bird every plant every atom if you
would wish every cell if you wish to go
down every Sun every planet being an
artist
in that first principle of always coming
back to the nature of this to reality is
where this show over the last two years
and change has evolved to this is not my
show the show is not for me me my and I
I try to not use as much as possible
that this is this is simply a vessel for
the one to play and that there is a
reason why this show came to that
question as the first principle what is
the nature of this reality because that
is what the one wants this show to be
and if we look at it this again in a
year will it still be that around the
nature of the reality my take is yes if
it's not I will be very interested in
what and then maybe the second principle
is about how every single one of us as
artists can be our best artist and that
seems to be the second principle of the
second focus of this show and of all of
the other multimedia content that were
we're working on yes that way we're all
all artists we're all creators we're all
creating something we're all here to
create something beautiful actually and
that the beauty is like highly
functional and effective even if just
for sheer delay and fun
enjoy and like why not exactly that my
friend of mine calls it um because it's
hardest hardest heart like a heart yes
heart hardest oh that's really good yeah
which actually art is the three letters
in heart yeah yeah I like that hardest I
like that a lot also heart is in many
ways what is the interval between
polarities of life and death is the
heart and it is also the if you if you
would endeavor with me into the science
is two-and-a-half billion approximately
heartbeats and seconds that you get
about thirty thousand days ten thousand
of which you'll be asleep so twenty
thousand of which you will be awake and
what will you do with your time and the
more that we remember those limited
amounts of summers that we have left
you'll get about if you're the average
age of the Saudis you'll get maybe like
50 more summers if you're you know lucky
like what what are you gonna be doing
who will you be surrounding yourself
with how will you be passing your time
what will you be hardest thing into the
world so that's that's such a part of
that second principle of becoming your
best artist is remembering
that yeah inquiry now about longevity
and that were conditioned to believe in
age and timing of like our body's
ability to thrive beyond a certain point
and because I'd see that like my step in
with my time light of this life and what
I'm here to create and either I'm doing
a lot faster I'm living to be like 250
I'm feeling awesome so you know it's
just a fun thing to decode like well and
look it up also our economic structure
political structure how that's framed
around an expectation or agreement that
you know age is like you're old when
you're 60 you're retire you're done
working you know etc and it's like how
such a deep and code men you know and
it's like well wait a minute I think in
the reality that I like to exist in is
like people are so turned on by what
they're doing what they're creating
living in their genius having a blast
I'm gonna keep playing yeah for as long
as I can oh very maybe a really long
time yeah radical life extension is a
fascinating field and it also tackles
one of the greatest challenges which is
the piece of art that is the human body
and keeping that like 14 year-old
homeostatic capacity with you throughout
until you're 80 until you're 140 etc
which is it's really beautiful to think
about being able to play for that long
it it also depending on what is actually
going on post death is potentially
unneeded so I don't know that's a that's
another in itself and another very
interesting question and topic is what
goes on post death because if you do
just take another seat in any of these
multi we're in this multiverse of
infinite multiverse
of creative play that's unfolding then
yeah then it's radical life extension
still becomes a part of it but it's also
hilarious in a sense to also think about
think about yeah there's so much to do
like there's so much that we accumulate
one of the great ways is the whole
library metaphor that's very powerful
because I don't want to I don't want to
lose the library that accumulates in
Sydney when she's 80 and like there's so
much good stuff in that library and then
the library like burns it down you just
file it away in the known field then
anyone can go access all of us are
card-carrying members and do I'm just
laughing at this like vision of like you
know we die and we make this whole big
deal about death and whatever and it's
like but then we just it's like but then
all we're all just kind of hanging out
in this other you know dimension and
we're like I wonder what happens with
all those people that are alive it's
like the same thing like nice to see you
again you know it's it's funny like we
can just laugh at ourselves in zoom out
like yes okay yes we're like God trying
to understand itself that nothing like
will never understand fully and we have
this great capacity to somehow by some
miracle be able to communicate as these
completely different beings with
completely different life experiences
like it is a miracle that you and I are
able to communicate and actually make
sense that's something that I've been
like very aware of lately like it is a
miracle whoa you know with how different
how unique we each are and how
differently we see the world like you
could describe something like I'm so
sensitive to assumptions right now and
I'm aware of how often I assume yeah and
it and how like all of the world's
problems are probably a result of just
assumptions and not being clear because
oh my god I could say this thing and
just assume you agree with the meaning
but you're meanwhile seeing it as a
completely different reality and it's
like it's a miracle that were even like
build things together
but this is part of the learning and the
remembering and the deconditioning that
we get to go into together as new earth
architects you know we get to be an
healing process to get there we get to
be in transformation together we get to
be the bridges between science and
business and spirituality and mystic
wisdom you know and bring it all
together so that we can really share a
common language a common understanding
without assumptions so that then we can
this is another thing we've never had
Mordor disposal in terms of innovation
technology resources I mean just like
human capital genius like we have
everything you know something an odyssey
we talk about is like we have these like
global challenges and issues and things
that we want to you know change and
evolving into a more harmonious state of
interbeing and the truth is like we have
everything we need to like solve those
issues but why is nothing but why is
nothing you know changing or why is it
not you know why are we not there yet
like are we there yet you know why not
and it seems to be that and I've seen
this in so many other examples too it's
like in in teams and companies even that
are like fully funded and they have all
the resources and all the right people
and all everything at their disposal and
they still can't like do the thing they
still can't deliver on the objective
that company fails so the issue is it's
like energetic it's behavioral its
conditioning it's like a lack of
intuitive emotional intelligence it's an
inability we must heal and transform our
inability and I'm so in this camp to
like I'm calling myself out because it's
really easy to operate in your own echo
chamber when it's just you and you're
running it you're running a company even
but men talk about real collaboration
like we are healing massively of a deep
like a series of wounds around real
collaboration like real sharing really
trusting really allowing ourselves to
show up as who we really are like really
being our full selves
in communion and community with fellow
masters a fellow equals that the people
that were here to build with because
it's all so easy to operate just on the
pedestal when I'm the CEO and I'm the
spiritual teacher and I'm gray and
everyone's here to see me and I can just
still be existing in my echo chamber but
you know when [ __ ] gets real this is
when it's like oh well you're really
smart too and you're really talented and
you're gonna mirror to me all the ways
in which I'm operating in insecurity and
inadequacy and fear and scarcity and
what's in the way of me being fully
present and actually sharing and being
in unity and so that's where we're at
right now like that's where we're at
that's where the future is just like
right there ready for us to build heaven
on earth is already here you know but
that's the stuff that we get to tackle
together and I like to speak about that
really explicitly because it to me means
like this initiation and rite of passage
journey that new earth architects and
leaders visionaries were called to go on
together and it's not about like me
going into my therapy with like my
one-on-one person yes I have all my
support I have my team I have my
different resources but actually it's
about all of us getting together and
like doing this work together and
healing the trauma and healing the
behavioral conditioning and like I need
to be experiencing myself in your mirror
to effectively release these old
patterns and actually learn how to
collaborate and share and trust
it's not even learned it's actually
remember to remember how to do that
because we know when we're in presence
when we're in coherence when we're in
true coherence right which is an
individual process before it's a
collective process personal mastery
personal development take care of your
own energy be coherent mind body spirit
soul stable clear connected then I can
meet you then we can start to create
coherence to get there and then we
multiply and then suddenly oh there's
more unity oh suddenly there's my ease
of suddenly there's more trust these
kind of these things can emerge innately
trust arises trust is there you know so
these are the kinds of things that I'm
really
excited about exploring now and creating
more intentional spaces for fellow
leaders visionaries of the new earth
architects of the new earth you know
having these spaces where we have
permission to like go into this mastery
of coherence because we had a practice
interesting so a big way of of
architecting that is by creating the
intentional living spaces so that people
can practice coherence to architect that
yeah yeah that's great what are some of
the principles at the intentional living
spaces it's funny that you said
intentional living spaces because I'm
like I don't want to live with anybody
funny that you said that did it sound
like I said that like I infer implied
living together
I was thinking where like like an
odyssey we gather in retreats and
immersions and there for like seven days
our last event was in November it was in
centers for four days so we'll you know
going forward we'll meet over seven five
to seven day period maybe ten days you
know but not but you know what yeah
ultimately yes practicing living
together practicing in real intimate
relationship yes yeah yeah this is this
is another one of those suds funny
balances that's imperfection absent
flows because we love our alone time I
guess I do know some introverts that
lived there a long time a lot and
extroverts that love their together this
time a lot but it's between the
individuality in the community because
the in the level of inundation today of
bings and boot pops that take us away
from our that both can take us into
community but also away from our self
work or just all these other things that
we're trying to do alone there's
something that's very complex about that
relationship
it does seem though that there is going
to be some sort of
of spaces that are designed in ways that
foster more of the the good miss that we
were talking about throughout the
conversation and so our ecology is a
main principle our architecture and
ecology being together another one is
keeping the Dunbar number in mind this
idea that it's so hard to fit more than
150 people intimately knowing one
another there's so many of these other
ones just obviously just not that like
immediate return hunter-gatherers were
super symbiotic with their environment
versus just stripping things away
creating excess hierarchies creating
just single mono cultures of agrarian
life I mean there's so many of these
things that were just that we can take
the good from and build into intentional
living spaces and make it so that people
can still easily have their
individuality within those you're like
Garret marrying something really cool
right now
that's very present maybe you're not
aware of this movie you are at some
level I feel you are you're marrying
this inquiry that I'm in right now about
you know moving to Hawaii and of course
you know this total synchronicity of
living situation arose was really funny
though it was like somehow I ended up on
this arbitrary website I've never heard
of before and I saw this great house and
I just sent them the email but it kind
of felt like well this email go to
anybody here is this like a real website
I'm not really sure but I didn't think
too much about it I just sent it and it
was like a very simple message you were
a cold you cold message of this place I
honestly sometimes this happens like
does this ever happen to you I end up on
the weirdest I fall out you know who
knows intuitive rabbit holes yes Peter
alright so the weirdest website sure I'm
like no one is this real website or is
this like a portal like what is thank
you like that and I'm like is this like
I wasn't really sure but I just sent
like two
sentences like hey is this place
available / is this real you know here's
my email and then the person you know
days later sends me this beautiful email
and is like oh my gosh we have all these
great friends on Facebook and I have
this beautiful property just built it
and it's you know was building it to be
an incubator or retreat center so it's
like this compound and it's communal but
everyone has their own private space
this is like Terry point it's like okay
there's little resistance of like
community there's not resistance but
just from some of my prior experiences
over the last few months I'm like that
can be really challenging
so yes it's important that when we live
in community we have our own private
space and this particular one the guy
just was like was on the phone with him
on my way here actually and he's like
yeah everyone has kind of their own
apartment basically you know but we're
all sharing living in the land and
there's like farming happening on the
land and there's ways of like really
being engaged with the natural
environment and and there's a big space
but there's this feeling of community
but also you know retreat space to
really be in one's own element like this
and you're talking about this now and
I'm like okay affirmation because this
is the future the future the future that
were here to build a unity consciousness
is requiring all of us to show up
together and to become masterful in our
relationship so that we can truly thrive
and live in community together and maybe
that doesn't know doesn't mean that
we're all living on communes but maybe
it does and maybe like so many of our
issues in our trauma and our suffering
has been the result of this overly
individualized amnesia especially look
at the family dynamic that's actually
like a really recent modern development
and very I would say specific to America
the way that the family unit has
developed right that whole and all the
pressure they're in of like how you show
up as a dad and the breadwinner and then
the mom and she's at home with the kids
but it's all like this this assumption
that you're kind of just managing it by
yourself and even the kids like everyone
has their own separate room and
sometimes the family doesn't even see
each other cuz everyone's busy and you
know versus
new clear eyes so that they're not
seeing the neighbor yeah exactly and and
then meanwhile and I'm sure there's
figures to support this but seems like
the majority of the world and maybe the
majority of our collective experience
and family has actually been more tribal
has been like you know living in
communal and like even sharing more
intimate spaces together so people are
actually you're kind of forced to be
rubbing up against each other and
healing and being with one another
there's not so much isolation and
avoidance and repression possible
[Laughter]
yeah the amnesia the species amnesia
does feel like there's a hyper amount of
communalism and also synchronicity with
mirrors being more greater proximity to
one another
mm-hmm albeit there's many ways to to go
from there and all also do one of those
pauses good job there's so many ways to
go from there
and I'm glad that you brought that up
especially regarding your adventure in
your next chapter yeah - y-yeah okay
there are a couple other things one of
them is what do you see
regarding inequality in the world yeah
hmm yeah it's hard for me to answer that
because when I tuned in and I asked like
what do I believe about this I feel like
I really Wow zoomed out so much like
inequality probably used to be the thing
that affected me most when it came to
discomfort and suffering in my human
experience on earth it's like so deeply
sensitive to even things like slavery
which I've never personally experienced
in this life but probably in other
lifetimes I'm just like I've always felt
so deeply impacted by injustice rooted
in really inequality like as obscure as
skin color I've always seen through that
illusion that like there's a difference
that we've created all these differences
based on like they're just it's always
felt made up to me and I spent a lot of
my life feeling like great suffering
wondering like what I was gonna do about
it how I could fix it why did everyone
believe this I mean that was like
motivated so much of my life and study
in all sorts of ways and now it's funny
because I just almost feel this like
neutrality about it like well I guess
inequality is there because people are
learning still learning about contrast
and learning about illusions in ways
that they create separation based and
like made up and but what do I see what
I see emerging what I see arising as
people are devoted and in more
disciplined to embodying more coherence
and embodying more mastery and like
living their purpose and being turned on
by life and exploring their intuition
and just being more awake you know what
I'm excited about naturally arising an
ascension is this very natural
remembrance and almost like uncanny
remembrance uncanny knowing that like
yeah you're my family you're my family
and I share of course I share with
everyone of course I want to take care
of the earth because I really take care
of my body so I'm really responsible for
my well-being and I'm connected to
everything else here
so I have a responsibility to take care
of all of this because it's actually a
part of me and so are you and so we'll
just net we're naturally already
arriving into the more and more of that
and so inequality feels like this kind
of like non sequitur thing now it's like
well I don't think that doesn't exist in
unity damn this is so beautiful because
on one side we have this beautiful unity
just wanting to awaken to the familial
and when you say things like seeing past
the the cultural programming of doing
skin colour stuff that's unity also yet
there's the there's the when you do add
eat that in and you do start breaking
that down you do see that like a
transatlantic slave trade and what that
how that trauma needs healing then you
you do see the the state of their being
2500 a billionaire's around the planet
and you do inquire into the you inquire
into their hearts and you wonder about
the amount of of love in their hearts
the amount of interconnectedness that
they feel how they accrued that wealth
and so because you oneness wants them to
feel like you are a sister and a child
and this is also a brother and a child
and etc so all children of the plan and
all brothers sisters of the family etc
but the way that the resources are being
distributed are not like trees through
their route through their roots and
fungal networks this trees that are
smaller trees distributing the carbon
excess carbon to them and in our case
it's someone left a comment on on one of
our videos I believe it was on the the
interview with with Chris Ryan that we
went from this immediate return
hunter-gatherer culture to horticulture
to hoarder culture and that's a really
interesting way of viewing it to I'm
getting another piece of designer
clothing or a boat plane car house watch
whatever meanwhile it's not a problem
that there are people starving homeless
disease-ridden poverty ridden that
aren't experiencing their maximal inner
artist and no problem that they're
getting kicked out of Metropolis is that
I'm buying the tenth and twelfth house
in that I'm never at because that
doesn't matter because real estates one
of the best places for me to diversify
my portfolio of wealth
there's lots that's happening like that
in the inequality a pot of oneness that
when we kind of like look into we're
like oh [ __ ]
and then let's within the architecting
we do have to open it up and and look I
think we're at a tipping point actually
just today on a call with one of my
mentors Randy we were talking about two
levels of inequality because it's oh
it's always referenced that's an
inequality gap it's always referenced
that way they're rich in the poor
right right there's the balance again
right - have-nots we today we were
talking about there being - I mean there
is this big spectrum of wealth but but
there's also a big spectrum of
enlightenment and some of the richest
people are some of the least enlightened
and some of the poorest people are the
most enlightened and so there's also
that which is something insane to also
add into this mixing pot and then when
we were talking about these gaps and we
started viewing it all so interestingly
a way of viewing it as there being a gap
between people that are buying their
twelfth house and people that are that
have a house that may be struggling to
pay for that house there's that gap but
then there's another gap down to people
that don't even make a one US dollar per
day so there's there's actually that
that selected like a billion people
that's left to not know about their next
meal and their next water for fucksakes
so there's that and then there's the
kind of middle ground and then there's
the extreme wealth so there's these kind
of like maybe even a two gap or anything
my way I see it i zoom out and I'm like
yeah and like what lifetime are all
these people on because at some level
you know to what extent have we all kind
of come in as understanding what it is
to be a slave what it is to be homeless
what it is to be a victim what it is to
be suffering what it is to be in
scarcity and then what it is to be the
perpetrator the.you know the harder the
prostitutes you I mean all these
different archetypes right it's like -
it I personally feel like I've played
all of those out and can even see in my
current life how I've still been trying
on all those different personalities how
I've you know and it's and so we can
zoom out and see okay at what level are
people choosing to play like that's the
game that they're they're playing that's
the game that they're choosing to
understand you know themselves better
within there they're here to understand
suffering being a victim being in
poverty for some reason maybe to realize
like oh that
you know the external externals are not
filling you know an innate sense of
worthiness or love or enlightenment or
connection to God or you know these
things that are free that cannot be
bought and but you know as you're
speaking and laying that out so
beautifully it's like again the
isolation piece just arises as we
continue to allow ourselves to be in any
isolation separation projection judgment
of one another really like liberation
and I think one of the most
revolutionary invitations for healing
any of us can inquire into is you know
and these are not my words but it's like
realize the other person is you yogi
bhajan says that like realize the other
person is you if we really are the one
and you and I are proponents of like
unity consciousness and let's be
together and let's see each other and
let's take care of each other and but
listen like that starts with me doing
all of that being all of that highest
integrity highest excellence like
feeling good taking care of myself being
in full responsibility being in truth
being authentic you know I got to get
that stuff underway before I can even
think about coming and playing with you
you know weird and we're not totally
there yet a lot of us who are even
claiming to be in great mastery and
teachers and facilitators and stewards
of great wealth and influence we get to
be really honest about whether or not
we're actually are we were actually
ready to play and collaborate in this
new earth yeah are we
yes bits I don't know I personally am
like I got somewhere work to do for a
little bit and you know but because then
we can't help like when we do arrive out
of the shadow out of the cave out of
this isolation out of the you know
projection that I've been allowing you
to put put on to me out of the when I
take myself off of the pedestal that
have been really comfortable operating
on you know when I actually just humble
myself and I'm really able to be here
with you the things that I used to value
don't matter so much so it's not really
what I want I think what we all really
want is like connection we all really
want is unity but we have to experience
that within ourselves first we have to
like
experience being with ourselves loving
ourselves it sounds so simple right but
it's like it's actually quite an
impossible challenging task like to
really deeply unconditionally love
yourself so that you can be in that type
of a union with other that's okay I
noticed as I say that it's like there's
my little perfectionism judgment arising
of like because I want I want I taste
moments of being there I can taste it I
want to live there I want to be there
but oh there's there's stuff and okay
and can I not judge and can I be in
celebration I've also like wow it's
taken a lot to get here I celebrate this
path I've enjoyed this journey I've
enjoyed the path even though the moments
that sucked and were terrible I thought
I was gonna die I'm so grateful for
being here present in this moment to see
how it was all great it was all perfect
maybe I created it all you know it was
awesome I'm a great game designer really
[Music]
there were a couple things that you
brought up that I thought were super
good of course that as we anchor
unconditional love in ourselves then we
get that unconditional love in the the
family of the ocean of
interconnectedness that all is in and
then I liked how you're talking about
all the different masks that we put on
to to play in all the different like
that a lot
and then important it's like if you find
that because this used to be me men or
so it's like so present right now I feel
if if you're out there and you're like
like those rich people and they have to
give back to the poor and those people
like whoever you're pointing the finger
at like that person if only they could
just get it and wake up and then we
could all ascend it's like they like
it's you it is you you know like the
people that bug you the people that
really that you're like you know got it
now you're giving a lot of energy to or
even like causative to like we gotta
save the ocean we got to clean the trash
we got to stop littering we gotta clean
the rainforest you know it's like the
stuff that you're giving the energy to
but that's really actually like
irritating agitating bothering you that
you feel maybe an obligation to fix to
serve to change it's like that's a
reflection of something within you that
probably you're not fully in
acknowledgment of or maybe not quite
willing to be fully present with like
are fully loving you're not willing to
fully love accept receive be present you
know - Sophie knows projecting out here
yet we also see that while also seeing
the stewardship of the millions of
species that are at risk of instincts
and so we do we do we do kind of have a
little fire within of wanting to
architect that which does not have such
extreme suffocation of natural ecosystem
but make sure you're doing the inner
work yeah and maybe after you do a
little bit more of this self inquiry of
like where am I
you know abusing the planet where am I
not which could mean where you're not
taking care of your body your planet
your ecosystem mmm where have you been
abused where have you been you know
perpetrated against where have you I
mean like we are at the planet like our
body is kind of our body is that
microcosm of the macrocosm is you just
want me to think about it so if you feel
this fire of like oh and by the whatever
the problem is out here it's like okay
just
take a moment and reflect like okay
interesting the energy that I'm upset
about in like the deforestation is like
this negligence this like you know
disrespect of natural resources and
disrespect of beauty and just like not
taking care of the earth and not taking
care of other people and you know but
then where is that energy that
negligence present within you like where
are you not showing up for yourself
where are you not managing your
resources effectively where are you not
energy your energy as I know is the case
for a lot of activists and people that
are on the front lines even in
transformation and spiritual healing
like you're on the front lines doing the
work but to what extent is that outward
drive to like save the world actually a
deep calling from within for you to
actually pay attention to yourself and
and I'm literally speaking about myself
in this moment like where is that Drive
and that call to service to the whole
actually and like with such great fervor
where's that actually a call for you to
look deep within yourself and see where
you are not giving that love to yourself
where you are not fully devoted to your
own awakening to your own highest
excitement yeah that's where it gets
real I love that way of putting it as
well that's why I'm always I feel trying
to look with nuance because then I look
in also with nuance and then I get more
of the variables and then I get the
complexity of what has taken as you know
a stimuli into this where I am right now
and also ask how everything is got
architected and then it's not a it's not
some sort of a pointing finger anger
type scenario rather a
a look at all of these variables and
feel the beauty and architect what our
hearts know is possible hmm that is the
process yeah you have a new book that's
coming out next year ish and you're not
sharing too much about it but you can
give us a little bit of a taste we would
love to the book is called the
consciousness code and it's a path that
I found to be really useful for
embodying higher consciousness and
living with more presents and greater
purpose being a creator of your reality
and it's been really humbling to have
written quite a bit and to feel now that
it's a lot of what has been created as
not is no longer relevant no longer
authentic so it's it's been it's been a
challenge and it's great I mean I guess
this is something to get used to as a
writer that you know we write for the
sake of writing and we we write because
it's something I love it's my art that's
what brings me so much joy it's how I
better understand and process and
integrate in fact the book is actually
it's like such a healing integration
process it's like the greatest gift I
could give myself to integrate this
journey of this life it's like all of
the lessons and can I digest it you know
can I digest it in such a way that
someone else may learn yes and quite
easily pick up the tools that I found to
be most helpful for I'm doing where are
the things we're talking about you and I
are super similar in that sense of also
having taken all of these different
beautiful spirits that have been here
sharing and trying to identify what are
some of the best principles and so
there's a very similar process I'm
curious for you for what you've
identified as these codes of
consciousness what as much as you would
like give us a little bit if you can
it's funny the journey with this book
started as like an invitation to write
about like purpose alignment fulfillment
like answering this call that so many
are feeling right now like I've been
this job and I'm not happy and what do I
do and how do I even begin that process
of asking what could be the other option
and then it evolved into more of like
sole purpose alignment destiny like
tuning and with you know a little bit
more of what we've been sharing about
like past lives and a little bit more
about energetics and and then it came to
this calling of like wait a minute this
is a man this needs to be a manual for
ascension yes you know and and I'm not
necessarily in here there's a lot of
books out there that are of about very
similar concepts I mean that's eight
step path
it's like Eightfold Path original I was
gonna be a 12 step path but then
publisher is like that sounds like it's
a little too 12-step II which I have a
background in 12-step recovery and I'm
like maybe it's 11 steps because I like
11 but there's this idea that there is a
path and there are many paths but I've
taken a path and I've taken a lot of
people down their path you know and so
I'm not necessarily interviewing a lot
of different people to get case study
user you know maybe that'll be a part of
what is revealed later on over the next
couple of months like that is something
I think I'd like to include more of that
type of research but it really is told
from my own experience how I've like
overcome addiction how would I've and
actually that's what I wrote about
before and as I say that that doesn't
feel true anymore and I really resonate
with what you said about being sensitive
to using me and I and
my because that's actually where I'm at
and that's kind of the awkward
reorientation that I'm in with this book
because I've actually told my story so
many times I'm kind of tired of it and I
want to be in this present moment
sharing and exploring and co-creating in
collaboration with the reader you know
co-creating this journey of what it is
to embody higher consciousness but
really in spirit of like supporting them
and being an inquiry like their
questions like the things that they're
excited to explore like doing their own
healing work with some examples and some
sharing but less less of that you know
and maybe more highlighting other people
maybe highlighting cuz it's already been
done before I'm not really saying
anything new you know I'm sharing
through my unique lens which might reach
people that otherwise might not have
ever heard it I'm clear on that but I'm
not really singing anything new I'm
tapping into like the same frequency
that everyone else writing about
consciousness is we all just have our
own unique transmission translation and
it's important for us to share that in
our utmost authenticity you know so yeah
I feel this process is very humbling I
have like the table of contents I have
the the step so you know some of the
steps and embodying your higher higher
consciousness are you know to become
really attuned with your desires yep to
practice radical forgiveness to you know
become really curious about your
intuition and how that speaks and wants
to operate in your life as a guide
to practice mindfulness they seem so
simple but they actually require in my
experience a lot of guidance a lot of
permission a lot of safe space to
explore you know it's like I remember at
a time in my path where I would just
hear all the time like just surrender
and just let go and just trust and
manifest and like reading Abraham Hicks
every day and wanting to believe it but
just always having this underlying doubt
and desire for someone to tell me how
because there's no assumptions and no
matter how much I read the things every
day I couldn't really get it I couldn't
believe it I didn't have an embodied
experience of what trust and surrender
felt like until I started showing up in
my life differently and allowed new
experiences to emerge that gave me the
opportunity to practice and so that's
what I intend that's like my prayer for
this new transmission that that's my
prayer is that it's like that invitation
into new action into new awareness that
people can have that embodied experience
of higher consciousness does that make
sense
those were excellent principles yeah
yeah there's some of them yeah and some
of them might change now - it's like I
have to ask you about some yeah well
he's one that it stuck out for me
which is this surrender there's
something also about it that it's like
okay but the architecting so what do we
is that another balance one surrender
but architecting it's a great balance
yes and it's an integration and and I
don't by the way have a step that's like
surrender how do I explain that it's not
an electrolyzed can't explain it you
can't well I'll do my best so yeah it's
a ballon
right like in this in this way that I
feel most excited there Yemen like
sensitive to the eye right mm-hmm and
the way that we're called to collaborate
in this new earth right and which is
rooted in sharing and Trust and
coherence connection you know we're
gonna become really masterful in working
with energy and creating in quantum
leaps creating what used to take us
years and lifetimes to manifest will be
creating it much faster much more
efficiently much more easily probably
with a lot more fun with a lot more
creativity because we'll become more
masterful of this understanding that we
create you know we create what we're
putting what we're intending what we're
thinking about what we were talking
about what we're envisioning we're
already creating it without us needing
to control the hell without having to
control every single single minutia of
how the architecture comes together I
see us all evolving into more of this
collective agreement and awareness that
we are really divine beings operating
with very like multi-dimensional
intelligence and capacity to literally
create instantaneously without needing
to know how and the why is simply
because we want and so it is and so I'm
excited to create like massive projects
with people operating in this and I've
already experienced some retreats and in
client containers it's like when we are
operating in this explicit intention to
amplify our magnetic potential you know
when we come into to harmony
through energetic practice through
meditation through breath work when we
get into these really ecstatic high
frequency states and then we play in
future visioning in like you know it's
2025 and we're I love your new flying
car I love oh my god so fun to see your
book on the bestseller list and my new
movies coming out and you know we just
speaking to being and we focus on
present moment a to meant to excitement
and ecstatic States and letting our
creativity and our intuition come
through and we give it voice I mean
we encode our reality we're always doing
that anyway we're just not doing it
consciously right what are we speaking
into being and so excited about creating
at scale and that kind of a way you know
and then allowing synchronicity and
really effortless useful manifestation
to simply occur cuz that is normal and
that does happen when you feel good when
you're in alignment when you're in flow
and focused on like really being a clear
channel we've all experienced this this
isn't spiritual it's like flow state you
know when you're clear when you're
making your art when you're just losing
total track of time you're in
timelessness you're just allowing total
focus hyper focus on what it is that you
love with like total presence you know
suddenly you've created you've written
the book in like three hours suddenly
you've painted the painting in a minute
you know whatever it is we've all had
States annexed state experiences like
this certainly when we were children you
know and so we all have that attunement
to remember and refine and so I sensed
you know this future and I've seen this
in many readings and reflections like
and that's where surrender comes in
right so we get to become masterful and
surrender of like okay wait a minute the
thing I want intellectually there's been
a conditioning that's told me that that
will take 25 years to build you know but
surrender and spirit and intuition
timelessness infinite being says no you
have infinite knowledge resources and
support available in all moments and if
you're really clear on what you want and
you know look at all this support here
amplifying this potential and so it is
so just focus keep focusing on the
feeling of how good it feels to have
that thing to be there to be to be in
the collective sharing and celebration
of that reality having manifested and
then surrender and let go and don't
worry about the how I mean now just
saying like basic Law of Attraction I
guess but there's a deeper meaning here
of like there's a somatic nervous system
attunement to surrender to peace to ease
to trust just knowing just like nature
isn't worrying about like I don't know
the wind blowing
you know like trees aren't like does
that sound funny like nature's not
worrying like I feel like we're really
just like we don't need to worry about
the how it's not our job it's actually
so ineffective to spend all of these
resources trying to figure out so many
things and figure out the how and make
the plan but is like operating in such
slow its operating so slowly actually
I've seen this a lot in the energetic
work that I support clients and it's
like in business especially with money
resources with manifesting a you know
scaled business or bringing a creative
project to life you know when you focus
your energy on like feeling your best
taking care of yourself clearing out it
you know lacking integrity clearing
energy drains when you focus on building
your full magnetic potential you know
suddenly the thing that you thought was
gonna take like however long based on
what you're conditioned to think in a
confined linear timeframe it's like oh
it just popped up because the person
just called me and offered me the
opportunity that I needed to like the
missing link to the puzzle
you know just introduced me to the
investor I mean of countless account
lists this is so these kinds of
experiences will get to go in the book
as like the celebrations and the
affirmations of what I believe is our
true nature I'll make the tie to the
next question as this
one plays out that the feel of what
you're communicating feels incredible
and also the there's also some sort of a
feel of leaders of governments or owners
of the largest companies in the planet
that makes it a little bit more hesitant
to so-called just surrender versus
actual architect so so yeah so that's
the one point and then that leads into
the question which is of I'd be
surprised that many of those people are
meeting with their you know psychic
energy advisors in secret and you were
actually very finely attuned with the
dynamics of quantum reality creation and
manifestation and surrender I agree that
that exists and that it's surprisingly
interesting that it does exist yet I do
not think that we have enough
conversation about the opposite the
psychopathic the complete and utter
domination of other people and natural
resources for individual greed
hmm so yeah so then those would be the
two points there of nuance that that
were great actually a great points of
nuance well one of my friends reminding
me of my friend Cara is an incredible
visionary advisor and like specializes
in new earth wealth and economic
dynamics and as a channel and Akashic
guides similar we share similar work and
she actually made this great point we're
doing a big council kind of deep dive
about the new earth economic system at
Odyssey and part of that came through it
was like this which i think is what
you're pointing to like this energy of
like sorcery like just kind of feels
like a powerful word that maybe we don't
use very often in conversations like
this but it really landed for me it's
like well something that we were
unraveling about the current global
financial system is like a few things
that a lot of the words that are used in
traditional banking funny enough have
these like deeply meaningful
significances and actually healing and
connection like think about the words
that we use to describe you know these
different aspects of banking bonds trust
like foundation there are a few other
ones but they were just very powerful
words that actually signify like at the
core a deep desire for connection for
unity for relationship like they're
encoded right and that felt very
paradoxical but then Cara made this
great point about how yeah like why do
you have these like multi billionaires
who are operating probably like
operating in such isolation and
disconnection from what it's like for
you know oh my god someone who's even
middle class or who even has like 12
houses not to mention as you said
someone who's barely able to survive you
know with like barely any needs met and
it's like wow what a crazy distortion
but what how has someone arrived to that
level where they're able to attract
magnetize magnify like that level of
resources within our current structure
and she literally was like this is
sorcery this is energy mastery you know
money is energy it's a current it is
energy right and so for someone's you
have a mess
asked and to actually amass a current
right like I'm just riffing on this now
but think about like amassing a current
like behind a dam you know like holding
a huge body of water say like the
currency of of money is like this
infinite river like infinite supply
hugely powerful think about the power
that it would take to contain that to a
massive to keep it like to hoard it even
like Wow and she called that sorcery and
I like to think about it that way this
leads into this question about what
being the purpose the Telos of this
entire process there is a feeling of of
humanity being a biological bootloader
for a digital super intelligence how
does that make you feel like the way you
describe that and that doesn't resonate
for me
I think computers and technology is just
a manifestation of our consciousness and
that sounds really simply put in kind of
silly to say actually like obviously
everything's a manifestation of our
consciousness but you know like the
Internet feels like a manifestation of
our innate ability to telepathically
communicate you know like the technology
this idea that there's a supercomputer
feels like kind of this dystopian kind
of strange play on like wait a minute
they trying to understand God something
that we can quantify something that we
can make tangible like a ration of
rationalization of God that's what it
feels like to me I don't really buy it I
think we are the supercomputer
we are the super computer making what
Wow making more we're the super computer
processing reality in such a way that we
activate more experiences in which we
can expand our processing capacity okay
and one of those may be digital super
intelligence how about I leave that
realm to you leave that room time I see
that timeline where we have all the
robots and we do all that but you know
listen call me an optimist I have a deep
faith in humanity really realizing
remembering awakening to its innate like
divinity and likewise incredible
potential to you know just just manifest
and actualize truly infinite possibility
that no computer or anything external
from us would ever be able to create
interesting perspective yeah what do you
think is most beautiful the first thing
that comes up and then innocence what
does that love you know love is love is
another indefinable is it is but that
innocence that feels true that flows
merge you to me in a sense it's like
clarity purity I could clean this this
prayer feeling knowing that we actually
all have the ability to create a clean
slate and that on that clean slate we're
just we are innately in our innocence
with like nothing to hide nothing to
prove yeah
to me
equally feels as important as the
youthful homeostatic capacity for
for life yeah
good weaving you to throughout this
whole thing this has been epic yeah
thanks so much for coming here
such a pleasure thank you I was like
well how many hours has it been that was
epic and on some level I feel like it
was like okay maybe that was like 20
minutes I'm not sure maybe it was like 5
hours I feel like we're right around the
2 mark awesome well it's been an
absolute pleasure
2:37 it looks like there was streaming
oh it does look like it's still
streaming ok well there's me looking at
the screen well okay well holy cow 237
wow wow wow okay so although our monitor
says that there was an error it's good
to know that it says to 3704 over there
and it's 34 meaning that error only
showed up like 30 seconds ago which is
also nuts cuz I hadn't noticed it so
it's because I've been keeping an eye on
it yeah that's strange
it's very strange jolt of your frequency
you see I'm so grateful
super enlightening so many great areas
explore together thank you thank you
thank you thank you thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear thoughts in the comments
below on the episode let us know what
you're thinking also I would love for
you to check out the links in the bio
below Sydney campus comm also her
YouTube page which has incredible videos
too
checkout on these topics check out the
page also her Instagram great profiles
follow that check it out and have more
conversations to your friends families
co-workers people online about all these
subjects that Cindy and I were talking
about please have more conversations
about these topics architect that future
that we all know as possible and support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
spiritual leaders around the world and
in your community so you believe in
support them and help them grow you find
simulation all of our links are below to
our show PayPal patreon cryptocurrency
and find all those links below and also
check out the visionary Souls podcast
that drops weekly that's visionary Souls
calm and that's a wrap
much love everyone thanks for tuning in
and we will see you soon
[Laughter]
that is a marathon it was a well man
let's see if it actually stopped because
it looks like it didn't stop it looks
like I might need to stop it another way
so let's see let's see how I can stop it
why don't why don't we keep let's keep
an eye hold this just like that for yeah
let me see how I can stop can you take
the comments at the green of salt you
two are not even ready to ascension
[Music]
and then you take this